Love her butt.
Sorry.
I forgot where the apex tab was.
I was like where was it?
So that's why that's why the video paused for a couple of
seconds.
I was like where's my where's my apex tab?
Good morning everyone.
Good morning.
I woke up like 15 minutes ago.
Let's fucking go
I love my 1230 streams.
Good morning, everyone.
Guys, did you guys notice?
We hit 700k subscribers.
We fucking did it.
Holy shit.
We did our very first official milestone together.
I think it was a super chat.
Thank you.
Congrats on 700k.
Thank you, everybody.
Our first official milestone.
is our first one because like you know when we came back
we're like I hope I get 500k before the end of the year and
now we're at 700k it's absolutely fucking crazy I can't I
okay I I'm sorry I don't have a gift for you guys to
celebrate it was just there's so many things going on every
day but don't worry there will be a belated gift it might be
a bit it might be a late but but i have i do have a belated
gift for all of you guys to celebrate bye thank you for the
super chat thank you thank you let's go congrats on 700k
thank you bite size thank you the super chat thank you thank
you thank you i'm i'm still like waking up slowly because
like i said i just i literally just woke up like uh 15
minutes ago d dragon thank you the super chat thank you
thank you congrats on 700k remember when you thought you
were going to have less subs good luck at taking eight later
today uh thank you the super chat thank you thank you guys i
am like uh i hope you guys are looking forward to the news
guys okay i don't know if you remember this but like um so
during that i think that jp apex legends tournament that we
did you remember how like on that stream i was like oh i
almost leaked something for next season so what i almost
leaked out for next season for this this was this was the
season i almost leaked out the solo modes
because you know i was told about the solos mode and the um
the solos mode and and uh the new legend and all that stuff
and um and i was like no it wasn't the besties it was the jp
apex legends and i almost because we were talking about like
solo stuff and i almost leaked out i was like oh you can do
it next season because there's solos gonna it's solos mode
and i almost said that that would have been such a huge
oopsie because mode is like a huge thing and i almost i
almost said it out loud i was invited to the place whoa i
was actually um you guys didn't okay i don't know if i told
you guys the story um but um i was actually uh i uh i was
told what the next update was gonna be so there was like you
legend which is basically like the better version of rate
and i saw like gameplay of the new legend because i've also
had like uh you know i i have like um uh a relationship with
the with the apex devs so like you know we they would like
tell me about what's going to be happening for next season
and everything like that and then so uh so like they
actually uh one of the devs actually wanted to invite me to
land uh because there was going to be an event at land or
something i think they wanted me to do the solo you know
there's like the solo showcase and everything so like one of
those actually wanted to invite me to land with like plane
ticket and like the plane ticket sort like paying for my
plane ticket and also like the hotels and everything and
then like also like getting to try out the the um getting to
try out the new next season for atlant but like i had to
refuse because i also had like a lot of stuff i couldn't
really travel anywhere at the moment because i had a lot of
stuff going on and also i was like to be fair i was also
really paranoid Because I was like, oh, I don't want any
photos taken.
Because I was like, I was like, um, I was like, wait, who,
how, who, is there going to be like other content creators?
And they're like, oh yeah, yeah, like we're inviting a
select few of content creators as well.
I was like, oh, okay.
And I was like, I'll think about it.
And I was like, okay, at that, at this moment, I was like, I
don't really, I'm a bit paranoid.
I was like oh I am a bit paranoid I feel like I was also had
like a lot of things going on in the background as well uh
so so I had to say no and I was like I would love next time
maybe next time I feel like a bit more safe like I think
it's also because like of everything going around about me
and then stuff like that I was also concerned about my
safety so I was just like well maybe next time when things
like die down a bit more so so I was just like if things die
down a bit more I'll maybe I'll try the next line I'll try
the next one brother thank you for the Akasu bye thank you
thank you so um so yeah that's what i was like uh i was
looking i was like oh man that looks so fun but like
obviously like they're like oh like um whenever if you ever
want to like we are we'll definitely have an open invite for
you um we'll definitely have an open invite for you if you
want to try the next line or like the finals or anything
like if you want to come over like we will we will like pay
for your hotel and pay for your like plane ticket and
everything and i was like oh sweet they're so nice to me i
really appreciate it um yeah there will always be a next
time there was always be a next time um yay thank you thank
you thank you just got back home for the trip glad to be
home and you made it to 700k thank you thank you thank you
yeah it was really sweet sweet of them i really love working
with um the apex devs because they're super sweet and
everything um anyway guys anyway it's time it's time to
check out the new apex uh the new apex game mode i'm not
gonna do solos first because i'm a little scared i'm a
little scared oh there she is there's edgy erase there we go
there's gonna be their reputation oh i can get people no and
like and she has a tail she has a fucking tail fucking dead,
look at that.
Oh my, you know what she reminds me of?
She reminds me of that Mutant in X-Men.
Fuck, what's his name?
What was his name?
what was that guy's name?
That's what she reminds...
Nightcrawler, yeah!
Nightcrawler.
Like, her toes even has, like, Nightcrawler.
Look, see... Okay, her toes.
Sorry.
Hey, hey, hey, hey.
Look at her feeties.
Look at it.
Yeah, she looks just like Nightcrawler, I feel like.
But yeah, she's apparently like the better version of Race
and like more fun from what I'm told.
From like my friends that have like playtested her.
She just looks like a...
What are her finishers though?
Dynamic exit.
Oh!
God, that's like...
Oh, it's like, that ability reminds me of another character.
I can't fucking figure it out right now.
Oh, that's actually pretty sick, though.
Bro, she's fucking crazy.
Bro, even the finishers are fucked up.
And then they...
Six days left.
Oh, Broken Moon.
Wait, what?
Why is there six days of fucking rank?
That does not make sense.
Hey, guys, I'm bronze now.
Anyway.
De-motion, oh, because everybody starts at zero!
Okay, we're gonna try her out.
Wait, actually, we're gonna try her out in firing range.
I forgot about that.
We'll try her out in firing range.
Let me see my volume.
It's okay.
Hit settings, audio.
Yeah, alright.
Alright, alright, let's see.
So, how the fuck do I use her abilities?
Oh my god, is this the range?
Oh, no, that's out of range.
Okay.
That's like, holy shit, the range.
Oh, wait, that's out of range.
Never mind.
Never.
That was not the range.
Guys, you know I can't read.
Many, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The legend is hot.
This legend is hot.
I'm installing Apex.
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
okay there you go it's like how do i get this to work oh
this is gonna be hard to figure out the range all right and
then what do i do then what do i do where the fuck is my
portal wait wait where do my portal go okay it's not like
that oh wait wait i figured it out i figured it out guys
okay all right guys i'm so i didn't read the actual thing i
should have read it okay give me a sec let me actually read
okay get from the rip can you really um interact with depth
okay i know about this i've heard about this my friends who
play tested this told me about this uh q could It creates a
passage through a surface.
So it's like...
Oh my god!
I get it.
So like, if somebody locks the door, I can be like, no.
And then I go through the door.
Oh, I see!
I see!
So you, doors...
So like, basically, it counters Catalyst.
So they lock the door.
I can be like...
I can be like, no bitch.
I'm in your walls.
Look, see?
There's like, this is door locked.
I'll be like, boom.
That's fucking right now.
I beat the shit out of that person right here in the corner.
Wait, can I drop from ceilings?
Oh my god, wait.
Wait, can you?
Okay, let's see.
We have 18 seconds.
What's the alt, though?
What the fuck is the alt?
Okay, wait, no.
Creates a regroup point that all allies can interact with to
open in the face toilet oh yeah so this is basically like a
two-way ash portal i see care package reveal care package
economy to see the highest okay we already know that all
right okay let's see we actually oh my god oh and you can go
back up wait that's that's huge look at that oh my god we
can actually like go through go from the ceiling that's
actually pretty cool yeah Okay, let's see and then And then
the portal.
Oh my god, we could drop down be like surprise fuckers Okay,
all right, we deploy, okay And then open portal And then
what happens what the fuck oh wait I think I used it wrong.
I Think I think I used the portal.
Okay, give me a sec.
I was confused.
Where's the altar here?
I was confused!
Go far away and TP, dude.
Oh, it's a return point!
Oh!
Okay.
And then...
And then what do I do?
Oh!
And then we, like, run, run, run.
And then, oh, we can go so far.
Look at that.
That's, like, how...
Oh, wait, no, that's the seconds.
Oh.
Yeah, and then we go...
I come back.
And that's everybody, right?
Oh, my God.
Wait, that is so cool.
Wait.
That is pretty cool.
It's a return portal.
I feel like that's...
Can I do it again?
Is that going to be, like, there forever?
Can I...
Can I do that again?
Why is it?
Oh, no, I can't.
I can't do it like that again Yeah, this guy is really it's
like night crawler and shadow cat.
Thank you super chat Jesse.
Thank you.
Thank you That's actually really sick.
I think I like this better No, I think I like this the most
because like the fact that like Doors are no longer the
enemy I think that's the she that's the most fun part no
longer will doors hinder me She's in here once.
No longer.
Welcome back to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
Doors and floors and ceilings too.
You can never hide from Doki.
You can never hide from me.
Peekaboo.
What are those?
That's right, Catalyst.
was can stop me nothing can stop me i'll just come in from
the ceiling all right yeah you know yeah you can't hide from
me no longer i mean that's pretty cool i really like the
abilities it seemed really fun it seemed like a a fun
character to play in general now the the question is will i
be able to play her that's the question peekaboo all right
let's see Let's see if I can play her Like, oh my gosh, the
way Oh my gosh, she's a fucking freak You know she's a freak
Alan, thank you for the super chat Thank you, thank you
Atomia is suddenly coming from your ceiling True horror
Thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you Alright,
here we go Here we go That's a cute name
She probably No!
give me I'm streamer let me play I stream oh yeah I'll be
the better I'll be the lesser version of you I guess
I'm you but less yeah look at my look at my badge you could
have had me on the new legend oh wait he won never mind
maybe he is pretty good he won the last game all right i'm
new but worse
no character on banner welcome to i almost said welcome to
overwatch because that seven hours of overwatch still lives
rent free in my head also how's the volume i forgot what the
default in general so like i might have like i might i don't
know if it's like too loud or not
we okay nice i got havoc that's seven hour oh yeah i forgot
the wingman is back on the floor all right it's back guys i
know there's no like digi threat though on the wingy Does
anyone else land here?
Hello?
Is anyone else here?
I don't feel like... I don't think anyone else landed here.
Control Legend Stock plummet.
Thank God.
They padded too good for too long.
Did you was deleted?
Yeah.
You guys hear the rumors?
Of like...
Wait.
Did I hear something?
No, that's not it.
Doki's tried to break out the streamer privilege she has
chases in 700k thank you for the super chat bacon i'm gonna
give him a chance to super bacon thank you thank you okay
look if you had the power that i had you would abuse the out
of it don't lie to yourself okay if you if you can like use
it to your advantage you would just like how getting early
access to things marvel rivals It's so true.
They're like, hey, can I have early access?
I'm a streamer.
You would.
If you had that opportunity, you would 100% do the same
thing.
Thank you for the magenta soup, but thank you, thank you.
Why did he land us here?
There's literally nobody here.
All right.
Oh, yeah, they took away skull piercer and a mag.
Okay, do you hear the rumors, guys, that like, that, like,
TSM might to spend.
That's actually fucking crazy.
There's like rumors going around that TSM might suspend
because of the performance.
And yes, yeah, because like, Verhoes and Verhoes and reps
tweeted out like very suspicious tweets today.
Yeah.
Did you start those rumors?
Did he not see?
They were tweeting out some very fucking suspicious uh
suspicious tweets they not like the org TSM but like the
apex uh the apex team are thinking about the spanning which
is fucking crazy because they're known as one of the longest
teams to get it like I mean not like Rehost but like Jordan
sorry reps I don't know why I said it.
I don't know why I said his first name.
Alright, let's see.
Ultimate reduced ultimate cooldowns.
Passive worms.
Whoa, don't get it.
You don't know him like that.
But yeah, it's at your... Oh, the walls.
I'm in your walls.
Alright.
Alright, give me... Holy shit.
What a fucking head glitch.
That's fucking right.
I might not have played this for a while.
Wait, where are they?
Wait, what the fuck?
Wait, what?
Oh!
Okay, nice.
I helped.
There you go.
I fucking helped.
Okay, let's see.
Nice.
We need that.
Oh, don't worry.
Don't worry, guys.
I got you.
okay never mind he climbed oh oh my god there he is okay
where are you i'll hit those shots i hit it i did it guys
did you see it bacon thank you for the magenta soup but
thank you thank you i'm morals okay dokey i do things a good
old-fashioned way through bribery yeah but but bacon better
than that?
Well, you can get things for free.
Dang.
Yeah, did I see that?
I hit all those shots.
I know.
It just happened so fast.
It's a bit hard to see, I know.
Wait, am I getting shot?
Or did he shoot me?
I couldn't tell.
Wait, what's this?
What the fuck is that?
Oh, it's like a little barrier.
Wait, that's so cool.
Okay, all these changes, they're not going to make up for
the fact that Broken Moon fucking sucks, though.
And we're going to have, like, several days of this, too.
Oh, they're near me.
Were my teammates?
No.
Nah.
Okay.
Where are they?
They're near me.
Oh, they're over there?
Alright.
Don't worry, I have my portal.
Do it again.
Don't worry, I got you.
Wait, where are they?
Oh, they're above me.
They were that near me?
Did they see me?
I don't think they saw me, guys.
I'm going on the roof.
I'm in your roof now.
There we go.
Whoa!
Did you see that?
Oh, shit.
Did you...
whoa did you guys see that look at the shots i hit whoa i
killed him that was me nice look at you go nice i knew i
could deal with that okay tactical one reduced tactical
cooldown i haven't played rafe in so long i don't even know
i didn't even know what her cooldowns were okay grab this
that's your streamer that's me okay oh wait is she chinese
she just said wait wait oh my god oh my wait is she actually
chinese wait that's so cool i just realized we never had a
chinese legend yet our streamer i was blinking against you
yeah yeah yeah those shots you thought i missed It's because
you were blinking, so you missed the frames.
Yeah, she said, wait, wait.
See?
Look, this is how I was supposed to...
I am hitting those.
I almost pressed Q for Conduit.
Q?
I've been playing Conduit for so long.
I'm going to go with that backpack from you.
Okay, maybe if I need him, he's going to have to push up.
Yep.
Wait, where is he?
Is that...
Is that mine?
That's mine.
Okay, wait, why are you running?
Oh my god, he's tap strafing too!
Okay, maybe I should- wait, what?
Oh, shit, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
don't worry, don't worry, bro.
Don't worry.
Is he rising him?
No?
Okay, let's clear him then.
Just in case.
Where?
I'm so confused.
Holy shit.
Okay, guys.
Does it look like I haven't played Apex often for a very
long time?
I did play Apex two days ago, just to be like, oh, shit, new
season.
But it doesn't look like I'm that rusty, right?
Right?
No, right?
I'm naturally talented, so I should look okay, right?
It's because, okay, I'll say it's because...
Let me aim at.
Oh, holy shit, he's so far.
Look, I have a perfectly good excuse for this.
Okay, guys, because I'm playing Wingman.
Okay, I'm playing Wingman, so that's my excuse.
Oh, and he's also playing Wingman.
Look, see, he's not hitting his shots.
It's just a Wingman debuff.
Whoops.
Oh, shit.
Okay, I was not expecting him to just be there.
Look, I hit one.
Look, one is one.
Wait, what?
Oh, wait, that's the mirage.
Where the fuck are they?
This team is making me so, like, confused.
Where?
Where the fuck did he go?
Okay, let me loot this guy.
first um boosted loader do i need wingman ammo i can't
believe i actually need wingman ammo all right look it says
i got two kills so like i'm not totally worthless
all right here we go where the where the is the other team
all right if i stand still i won't get hit I'm going to blow
my nose.
Just give me a sec.
Surely I wouldn't get shot at.
All I'm saying is that the shots you don't see me hit are
the shots that...
Wait, if I use this, does it expire for everybody?
Oh, they're near me.
Does it expire or does it still stay up?
She don't know how this works
No, no, everyone gets one use Oh, oh, I see Okay, but yeah
You think I don't hit those shots But because you're
blinking You're blinking to the frames of me hitting shots
You can hear it But then if you don't see the visual The
visual effect of the shot hitting It's because you blinked
that's it's so fast yeah you just couldn't register it like
all of you guys too i can't believe it's like i can't
believe all of you had that experience too that's actually
what are the chances what were the odds of that happening
it's like one to a million and you were there it's like a
natural phenomenon pertnaid oh shit is this horizon queue a
new visual oh my god okay this team is actually goaded what
the fuck I did it all right oh there's a bow I feel like I
hit more shots with a bow than the fucking wingman at this
point wait behind us wait who do I go to I'm gonna go to the
cat.
I did it, guys.
What is he trying to chase?
Hello?
What does he want to do?
They're close to me.
But I won't let them know that.
Gotta keep them on their toes.
I hear them.
Yeah.
Please.
I told you!
I hit more shots!
With the bow!
I fucking knew it!
Oh shit.
Okay, here you are.
I knew I hit more with the bow.
I should full heal actually.
Look, it's been so long.
Wait, that is him.
I thought he was just like a mirage with those.
Oh shit, maybe- shoot hey
guys i forgot when you climb it can't hey sorry guys they
hit me guys oh my god guys the their bullets like fucking
curved guys it was absolutely insane team that bullet curve
that guys did you see it they hit those us it was insane the
fucking bullet curve there holy shit the bullet curve it was
absolutely crazy max i know right oh my god they already got
a kill i was there i'm gonna farm some damage so i won't
look like total ass
There we go.
I'm going one more team.
Yay!
We did our first game!
I was part of this team!
Yay!
I was part of the process.
Let's just leave.
Let's just...
Wait, as a party leader, you can re-queue the party if you
exit at any time.
Wait, what?
Well, I also have to return to...
Oh, wait, that's...
What?
No, fucking...
Oh, oh, I wasn't the worst!
Guys, I wasn't the worst one!
Wait, I thought I did so little damage!
But I actually did just enough!
I didn't...
It wasn't me!
Guys, I realized I was actually good.
Oh my god.
I was just enough.
I was the middle of the pack chat I was the middle of the
pack I blinked it did oh now you blink now I was in the
sandbag all this time I was part of the process I fucking
knew it I knew I was in the sandbag oh thank god I can play
this character now middle i was average that was just enough
look i did play wraith which was her but worse she was mid
let's go let's fucking go is it this is me
yeah it's the new chap um i already forgot that's me that's
me i forgot her name already what's her name altar Is that
her name?
No matter how much they change this map, this map will
always be ass.
I can't change my mind.
Sorry, I was blinking too much.
Cosmic, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Is it altering?
Yeah, okay.
Because it doesn't change the map.
It doesn't change the size of this map.
Which is what was the huge problem.
Because the map was too fucking big.
I mean, like...
Yeah, I just think the map is just too big.
I forgot broken moon existed we all want to forget broken
moon existed this is like a nice cool design place but still
pretty fucking a terrible map I don't think anybody likes
broken moon in general I don't think many want to actually
like this goddamn map hello can I steal your stuff Oh, I
want to do triple.
Oh, actually, I really want to play triple take for like one
fight because triple take is still an ass gun.
All right, let's see.
Oh, wait.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Boom.
Where this is going to take me?
Oh, right here.
All right.
Wait, where is the person that she's fighting?
Oh, I hear him.
Yeah, that's fucking right.
you okay i was gonna say you better not die to that because
i literally like whoa
hello hey thanks for the loot
nice wait what wait what oh shit this is bad wait this is oh
i was like wait two
add up this number this number does not add up how is there
two when i killed two already i might be bad at math but i
know when numbers don't line up
two two plus two equals three that ain't right what the fuck
happened oh it's the same team again We're running it back.
The non-existent win streak.
It's them again.
All right, these guys better fucking pick up the slack.
Because I got two.
I got my twos.
One of them.
Wait, no.
Actually, I got my one.
One of them didn't get their ones.
Who was it?
Who did not get their ones?
She's making people up again.
Wait, this guy got a rookie badge.
legend.
I wish I can get a rookie badge.
Cosmic.
Thank you for your super chat.
Thank you.
Sorry.
I was blinking more again.
Okay.
Alright.
You guys.
Run it back.
It's revenge time.
You're diamond.
You better impress me.
Who am I kidding?
He's diamond.
He's already disappointed me.
Oh, am I kidding?
Alright.
Let's see.
We're gonna grab the G7 Scout.
We're gonna get rid of the G7 Scout because I'm fucking
terrible at it.
Oh, I hear people fighting in there.
In there?
In here.
There's so many.
Oh, there's people.
I hear people next to me.
Or am I fucking going skitsa?
No, there are people next to me.
I see them.
They went through the portal.
He doesn't see me, though.
Alright.
Watch this.
Peekaboo!
Oh!
Okay.
That was a little ambitious there.
He peekabooed back.
I didn't expect him to look back at me.
He knew.
He stared back into the void and shot me.
That's crazy.
I can't believe he shot back.
That's the craziest thing you can do.
Wait, there's like two different teams here.
Oh shit, no, come on!
I did so much damage!
Hey guys, nice.
Steven, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Good luck on the new season.
Thank you.
Okay, oh no.
I need to grab the armor.
How do I, like, grab stuff from other people's inventories?
Because that should be, like, my special, right?
I should be able to grab stuff from other people's
inventories.
people's inventory.
Extend highlights to help bars after it reduces cool down.
I feel like extends highlights to help bars after exiting.
Really, that's good.
Just look from afar.
Oh, okay.
I got this.
I understand.
I actually do understand.
I'm not like saying it.
It's not like the old I understand where I don't understand.
And I'm just saying it just because I don't want people to
think I don't understand.
Oh, man.
is all right but i actually understand for real this time
like
i actually understand guys and i'm not saying it all right
don't worry i got this i'm gonna help my team wait can i
steal this let's see okay i can steal from each box oh my
god i can steal from each box wait That's so cool.
Wait, I love that
I I fucked up I got shot by three people
I don't know I don't know guys.
I don't know I don't know maybe they're gonna swing I don't
know whoa, okay Okay, oh my god, okay
Are they still in that corner?
oh my god no no please why is everybody here please just
shoot each other okay i understand don't worry they're
shooting each other guys he's right here he's right here
he's gonna he's right here loot please loot the box oh god
my greed my greed got the better of me use the portal guys i
should have used the portal and ran through the walls
somehow it's okay we have a conduit that means like
somebody's gonna she she can like craft us look i'm still
learning the hero i'm still learning this is like my second
time playing here guys come on does she not have shields
what the fuck is her shield.
Guys, pick me up.
I'm important.
Guys, it doesn't look...
Oh, she's coming back.
Okay.
She knows I'm important, guys.
See?
I knew I was important, guys.
I knew I was the main character.
Even she knew I was important.
She came back.
How important?
I got my banner picked up.
That's important enough.
No streaming.
Yeah, my streamer privilege coming in clutch again.
Oh my gosh.
I'm looking.
I know like, okay, I was going to say it.
I know like I said that we were, you know, that this week
was going to be a rest week.
This week is not going to be the rest week, by the way.
You guys didn't know.
Oh, it's not.
Too many things came up last minute.
but I'm also like super looking forward to um I'm looking
forward to Hades too uh I was like um that like oh my gosh
the sudden drop the Hades 2 drop out of nowhere that's
actually crazy the fact that we have Hades 2 before anything
about silk song like all the silk song I love silk song
waiters out there
Hades 2, let's go.
The Silkson Copeum.
Guys, no, it's gonna come out soon.
You guys don't know that.
It's just...
It's just because, like, Hades 2.
Hades 2 is an early axis.
But when Silkson comes out, it's gonna be full of axis.
You guys don't understand.
You gotta do me like that.
Damn.
Anyway.
I was, like, looking up, like...
I was like, okay, because it's early axis.
like okay so like how much content is actually in there and
apparently like majority of like the story content is like
actually almost done it's mostly just like the the little
things in the game so okay reduce tactical boy next next is
no longer times out wait that's that's so cool wait where's
my teammates oh they are far i'm gonna go to my teammates
again yeah it's just end right yeah most of the gameplay
seems to be there though like it's just the little things
it's just apparently the ending is not so like you it's all
it's technically like hours of gameplay which is crazy to
think about that that is early access and it's already like
hours of gameplay oh goodbye sir okay those shots were
fucking nasty you have to admit that
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh my god.
They actually thirsted him.
Holy shit.
That poor guy.
That poor guy actually got thirsted.
Okay, you have to admit, that was a sick-ass shot I did on
whoever this guy was.
Tom Lee.
I didn't even need to use my ability.
bro panic ulted I mean I would too after I fucking
demolished his teammate like I'd be fucking concerned okay I
don't like the sound of that I heard names but from where am
I hearing things again I might be hearing things again I'm
gonna steal something from our teammates
Oh, I wasn't hearing things.
I fucking knew it.
Watch this.
Peekaboo.
Oh.
Okay, I saw the health bar.
I was like, teammate?
Whoa!
Not gonna lie.
I actually thought it was my teammate, but I forgot that was
my ability.
I was like, wait a minute, health bar.
That doesn't make sense.
Okay That actually doesn't make sense, but it was I I made
it like that Team main
Okay, all right, okay, I knew that was not teammate this
time I This time I knew Can I like steal something?
Hey
I'm gonna put this here All right, here we go, we're fine.
I think there's, like, another team here.
I feel like there's another team here.
Where?
Where did you get shot?
This guy?
Oh my god, okay.
All right, push.
Resim, Resim.
I'll protect you guys.
Resim.
I got you.
I'm covering.
Where is he shooting at?
I was like, what?
Okay, that poor man.
Also, I realized I did not loot any shield cells.
Let me steal that shield cell real fast.
No!
I stole fucking health!
Okay, okay, that'll just loot it the old-fashioned way.
Like, it was just reflex.
It was actually just reflex.
Maybe the loot the first thing I see.
I was like, ooh, gold helmet.
That's a nice loot there.
Whoops.
Not mean to press my Q.
What a team player.
That's a weird looking shield, self.
All right, what else can I steal from there?
Wait, this is so convenient.
I can just casually steal things.
All right, let's see.
Let's grab the scope, actually.
Wait, Did he took the scope?
Wait, he took the scope.
There was a scope right here.
He actually took it that fucking madman Okay Alright, wait
they took it down.
No, I took it down.
Whoops That was an accident actually I was like wait a
minute where did it go?
Wait, it's one guy.
I think it's one guy Yeah, we were...
No, it was not one guy.
I didn't get one guy.
I knew I didn't get one guy.
Watch this, guys.
I did it.
Do you watch it?
I told you.
Look at that.
He died without me even looking at him.
Oh my god.
I watched it.
Nice.
What?
What happened?
I was so good They died from my mere presence That was how
good I am Look middle of the pack I take those I take middle
of the pack Incredible Amazing battery What a fucking gamer
I know Wait I think I got cool I got cool icon What was it I
got cool badge What the fuck Oh I was like What is that I've
never seen this before Where's like the legend badges okay
where's it no i want people to know i gotta win i gotta win
it's the same team fuck this shit it's not you i want to
play with new people i don't want to play no it's not them
guys i just want to play with new people Not three times in
a row.
Okay, where is the legend badge to show people how much of a
gamer I am?
Okay, only things I've unlocked.
Where is it?
Where's my face?
What the fuck?
I thought I unlocked it.
Did I not unlock it?
What?
Where?
Where is it?
Okay, let's see.
What did it look like again?
It was like...
there it is alter there you go now they know i oh now they
know i want a game cosmic thank you super chat thank you
thank you sorry i got that sorry if that got in my uh bro
fucking wait what
oh jet player man well he wanted to play rev 2 didn't he
just keeps happening no i should just leave i should just
leave fuck this man
yeah where the fuck is your print badge jet plane man you
really deserve to are you okay are you even are you even
chinese that's making i should not be able to play
I'm eating tangerine.
Alright.
True.
Damn cake keeping.
I should get first choice.
Cancel that guy.
Right now!
They're pulling my streamer privilege.
Oh my god.
There's no gun.
Right, bitch.
Shit on.
Oh shit, I might get shit on.
Literally have a P20.
Missed the first 50 minutes.
Can you give me a rundown?
I hit 100% the shot.
I took.
That's a TLDR.
You missed it, guy.
You missed it, man.
I won, like, five games in a row.
Oh, my God.
Truly, like, the best streamer content out there.
There is another team here, because I got scanned.
Are you a fucking coward?
I literally, like, killed one of them.
Why are you so scared of?
Where could he be, though?
I know he's scanning me here.
he oh wait i see his scans i see you i see you you scan
yourself you revealed your location to me i should grab this
actually i should grab the r9 wait here whoa don't worry
don't worry i'm gonna run into his face wait where did he go
i did it you saw that
shots wait is he is she speaking cantonese wait i i can't
tell like she said something that seemed like cantonese does
it matter yeah she speaks canto yeah i was like wait a
minute wait a minute that sounds so familiar i couldn't
exactly tell what she said but like
Not like loud enough, I guess.
What the fuck?
Are you running?
Oh, you have friends.
That's not fair.
You should respect this 1v1.
Oh, God.
Somebody's not respecting the 1v1.
That's right.
That's what you get for not respecting the 1v1.
Oh, that's right.
You can't fucking...
Alternate it!
He's right here.
Don't die or you're fucking bad at this game and you should
honest up, but not me.
I wasn't bad.
I just got I just got three-partied
That doesn't relate to me though that doesn't relate to me
That's so cool though and she speaks Cantonese I like
understand her Totally not bad.
It's not bad me it's never me I literally have streamer
privilege what's the point of being a streamer if I can't
use this privilege like what's the point it's like when
you're rich but you don't use any money it's literally the
same thing like like what's the point okay that was
embarrassing that was actually so bad.
So Keanu Reeves.
Wait, the resin.
Don't let him do that to you.
Oh.
So true.
It's true for my privileges to not.
What?
Rich people stay that way because they don't use money.
What are you talking about?
Okay.
That is not true.
Wait, he's seed?
What?
He's like...
all right we leave we leave fucking leave what am i playing
on okay i'm playing on full screen i guess we can try solos
now we'll try solos there's no way that guy tc do this
finishers i feel like there's like more characters with like
uh i feel like i've seen i've seen like this finisher um
like this type of move done before i'm trying to remember oh
perfect cell that's what it reminds me of it reminds me of a
fucking dragon ball z yeah i was like wondering like why the
fuck does that kill like it's so similar it reminds me of
like more like cell one yeah i think It was, like, cell one.
Uh...
Imperfect...
Imperfect cell.
Yeah, his first form.
Yeah.
That's why I was like, that's so familiar.
It looks like the...
Like, a cell finisher.
Yeah, now it makes sense.
Is she Girl Boss Cell?
Doesn't it...
Like, it just reminds me of the animation for Cell.
Oh, yeah.
Nobody can steal it now.
uh maya thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
alert if you are seeing this message you are in danger of a
mysterious life form known as a woman derogatory has
breached containment do not engage lock all doors and
windows your virginity is at risk thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you
all right solo time
Bracket derogatory.
Let's see.
We'll go...
I wanna go...
Where do I go?
Where do people go?
Okay, I'm gonna look at where all the other solos go and
then like...
Ooh, enemies nearby.
Tells me where the enemies are?
That's sweet.
Alright, so they're all here fighting each other.
I can take these little...
little bit of lutes here.
Ooh, glue, Spitfire.
That caught me off, I think.
Oh, oh, they're all like, it's all like, uh, oh, that's
interesting.
They're all, like, already kitted out.
Oh, I like that.
Okay, we'll grab the havoc, and then we'll go in.
I feel like playing as this character is not five years, 21
seasons, and I'm still trashed.
my god poor guy i don't know about playing as altar would be
good for this character i don't know for solos mode i'm not
sure if i like solos mode for altar it feels like harder
definitely oh wait what oh oh what i what i get oh i get to
go again okay I don't even I don't even know what happened I
can't tell what the fuck just happened to me it happened so
fast am I gonna die here it's fine okay I see somebody over
there.
Alright, that's my death location.
I was there.
That's fucking right.
It's fine.
Another team is shooting him.
Wait.
Oh, wait.
What the fuck?
I see you there.
Okay, why is everybody coming to me?
This place is like no man's land.
Well, I see you in that smoke.
I see you.
There you go.
I saved your life.
all right oh fuck oh this is in my life though bro try to
save your life where's my payback dude i blinked and your
help disappeared that is a good question what the fuck
happened to me what if i just go here all right there has to
be a oh there is whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa no no no
no no no no no no no wait how many lives do i have oh i get
death recap okay that was how many lives i have
guys i figured out how many lives i have you get two lives
okay
that's good the best part of solo is that you need to carry
yourself down thank you super check out they could thank you
i was totally carrying myself those two wins I got I was not
the I was not the problem those games that one I was I was a
fucking helper I was middle of the pack helping you can
requeue yeah keep forgetting to requeue I I was just so used
to just going back to the menu Israel thank you for the 10
gift of ships thank you thank you you.
Friend, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I blinked myself for a second and you, uh, I blinded myself
for a second and you died.
What happened?
I won.
I didn't die.
You see, the great thing about blind people is that you can
lie to them.
Because they can't see.
But I didn't lie to you, friend.
Uh, of course.
I would never lie to you.
That was not a lie.
Just, Just so you know, that was not a lie.
Okay, I got...
Who has a better trade-off?
The PK and the alternator?
Bro, that's not
right, bud.
What?
That's messed up.
Don't worry, not just blind people.
It works for deaf people, too.
That's funny, guys.
I didn't lie though not this time Okay, I have an enemy near
me This is so fucked up How come I get the charge rifle?
Like, where are my benefits?
Oh, and then he gets the fucking What was that?
Is that Spitfire?
Cashew, yeah, is that great?
I won See?
I hear him He's like right over there
Okay Here he is.
I see him.
He's just looting.
Wait, I hear more than one.
Bro!
Fucking let me breathe!
Fucking fuck this.
You guys fight each other.
I'm going out of this portal.
I'm going out of here.
You guys fight each other.
What?
You fucker!
You actual fucker.
You there's literally people right here.
I can't believe it.
You chased me all the way here Where's the other guy?
There's there's literally one other guy here and he
disappeared Is he also blind?
Gator.
Thank you.
How are you gonna say that about blind people?
I told my friend what you said and he typed it was personal
I got the only reason why dude okay I'm gonna say this
character sucks for so long
Lance thank you for the magenta soup but thank you thank you
did I blinked okay I blinked and you were running away what
happened thank you with magenta soup but thank you thank you
I'm saying is that I picked the wrong legend for this I
picked the wrong legend for solo's mode this is definitely
not a solo's character at least I had fucking conduit shield
it's like extra shield what do you mean I don't know
actually I'm trying to think like what would be a good solo
character I guess like Bangalore.
Bangalore or, uh, maybe Bangalore Wraith Pathliner is for
the mobility.
I feel like Alter is definitely a team character.
Okay.
There we go.
We got it.
We got Wingy and the Prouler.
That is an improvement from a charged fucking rifle.
Definitely a huge improvement.
Oh my gosh, I hear so many shooting.
Ooh.
Okay, wait.
What is this for now?
Actually, no.
We'll go with this.
I don't want to run double.
I don't want to run double heavy.
All right, let's go.
Ginger, thank you for Super Chat.
Thank you.
Man, I think you dropped this.
Oh, my God.
Thank you for returning my $20, Ginger.
I really appreciate it.
It's crazy.
I dropped so many cash today.
It's actually...
It's...
Okay, am I getting shot by two people?
Why am I getting shot by two?
Please!
Why can't you get shot by two people?
Oh my god, bro, I dropped so much money everywhere.
It's like literally everywhere.
Guys, can you help me find my money?
Bro, okay, I swear if it's this guy, I'm fucking gonna try.
That's fucking right.
Run!
Run, you bitch!
You seem like a guy that fucking shoots people in the backs.
There you go.
Oh, fucking hell, I'm so mad.
Finally.
I got our actual 1v1.
Let's see.
I finally got my own 1v1 and I won it.
I told you it wasn't me!
I kept getting shot in my back!
It's you.
That's right, it doesn't- it's not fun, right?
It's not fun getting shot in the back, right?
Wait, do I not have shields?
There he is.
No, no, no!
That's not fair!
I'm supposed to shoot people in the back!
Hey, I found a random here says it's blonde so yellow but
also tomato bird.
I wonder who that is.
Super thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, maybe I'm gonna...
Okay, not a solo player.
Not a solo character.
Alright, fuck this.
Wait, not...
Wait, what?
I picked...
I picked Bangalore.
Oh, wait, what?
Oh, what?
That was so weird.
Guys, thank you for finding my money, guys, and returning it
back here.
Thank you guys so much.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The crutch character.
Is this yours, ma'am?
It was stuck in the blind person's pocket.
Mr. Broken Fun.
Thank you for the Akasupa.
Thank you.
Oh, my God.
Thank you, everybody, for finding my lost money.
A fucking gorse from the person you least expected.
A blind person.
Bro.
What?
Oh my god.
Thank you everybody for finding my lost cash.
Hey I saw you drop this but why do you have British
currency?
You know I just like to collect money ever so often you
know.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you Leon.
It's just like to collect.
It's like collecting coins except like money.
This time, this time will be different Blind people being
put on blast Hey, hey It's not just blind people But also
deaf people
Ah, yes, collecting money Alright I fucking swear If you
guys get a better gun than me I swear to God
Where is he There's two people here.
This is fucked up.
Oh, he ran away.
He took the zip.
Okay, thank God.
One enemy nearby.
I hear him.
Please make this an actual 1v1.
That's all I asked for.
We're both bad.
Oh my god.
secure you're actually worse holy oh my god poor god this is
it this is it a proper 1v1 they've told me about this no
that's not a proper 1v1 anymore i saw him running over yeah
i was like
Oh my god, it's not a proper 1v1 again
Come on I'm gonna chill Fucker, you fucker You came back He
came back You bitch Why?
You want me to have a proper 1v1?
And he got it's the same he came back for revenge Bro, okay,
bro fuck this two last bullshit.
It should be one life Like it should be one life because
they get to play like a fucking pussy Like this shit sucks
This is bullshit They come back for revenge just like what
I'm about to do I
Where is he?
Where the fuck is he?
There's no way I'm the last third partier.
There's no fucking way.
Oh my god.
He actually came back.
I...
Bro!
This fuck sucks.
Like...
What
can I do?
Like...
Every time!
Every time I shoot one...
Every time I shoot one shot...
I get shot in the back.
Get out of the way.
This is...
Bro, I just keep on fucking sucks.
Everyone should have one life.
Like, it's just because they'll come back.
They keep coming back.
That's just bad luck.
Use...
Everyone...
Yes, but I only...
Okay, I'll show you guys how...
Would not change anything.
It will not change anything.
People will still fuck me over.
Always expect a third party.
Bro, it's like non-stop.
That's the worst part.
Bro, like...
You need to be able to come back.
The dead should stay dead.
The dead should stay fucking dead.
Like what is this bullshit?
They keep coming back and shooting me in the fucking back.
I'll be back.
Okay, there's three people here.
Surely those two will fucking shoot each other, right?
Oh my god.
Let me land in the middle of these guys.
Surely I fucked up a little.
Okay, I'll be in here now.
I'm gonna live underneath you.
Wait, I could go here.
Bye.
Wait, he's gone.
Okay.
It's not that bad right now.
Okay, they're shooting each other.
They're shooting each other.
That's good.
That's so good.
Wait, okay, wait, I got a plan.
I got a plan.
Wait, this is a good plan.
But this plan is brilliant.
You can't third-party me if I shoot from the distance.
Alright.
Okay, here we go.
Alright, this is it.
I'll just stop.
Shit!
I'll just stop pushing people.
I'll just stay here.
I'll just fucking stay here.
Listen, we discovered the play.
This is how we gotta play this.
It's if I just stay here.
Don't push up.
I have a sniper.
Oh, God.
He came back for revenge.
Don't push up.
I have a sniper.
Where are they coming from?
There's no way he pushed up, right?
There's no way.
Why are they all coming to me?
Guys, guys, look, I'm...
There you go.
Oh my god, he had the same plan!
That's illegal!
That was my plan!
How can he have the same plan as me?
I don't...
How did he have...
What?
He also has the same plan!
Why are they all sniping?
Bro!
They're all stealing my ideas!
This is so fucked up.
They all stole my idea.
Like, I had this idea first.
Now everyone is sniping.
I had this idea first.
Why are they all stealing from me?
Oh, wait.
Wrong one.
It's okay.
I'm better.
No!
He's so low.
He was so low.
I gotta crack one of them.
No!
What?
Fuck off!
I'm trying to snipe.
This is so messed up.
I can't believe my ideas got stolen.
Is this how...
Is this how my hero felt like?
Thomas Edison.
This is how my hero felt.
Where is he?
Oh, he DC'd.
Nice.
Thank God.
Trip at him.
first is the same guy it is the same guy that got on
let's go thank you for the super chat thank you thank you
keep complaining about them is he gonna peek me again for
stealing my fucking ideas that's that has to be a tesla set
seeing stealing ideas that rightfully mine that's what dude
got shit on twice he got shit on and fucking ran away like a
little bitch but okay let's see he's still sniping I
literally saw him fucking sniping from 20 miles away look at
him he's still doing it this is 180 oh he's like running
away from me too.
That's the funny part.
I can't believe this is solo mode.
This is the longest I've ever lived just because I'm playing
sniper.
This is actually the longest I've ever lived.
It's so sad.
Where am I just shot from?
I want to know where the Mirage guy is.
Rajgat has so many shields.
That's like the craziest part for me.
How does he still have the shields for this?
No.
Oh, no.
You don't get to fuck me over here like this.
That's fucking right.
I'm a better sniper.
Bro, everybody here is just sniping.
Bro!
What?
Why?
This is my area.
Leave!
Literally, everybody here is sniping.
Actually, leave me.
No!
I don't have shields anymore!
Oh my god!
Like, leave me alone!
You started this, Joki!
I didn't think everyone was gonna snipe!
I literally have zero shields.
How
did these guys have the shields?
for this.
Are you serious?
People are in my home!
Oh my god.
People are- Bro, fuck off!
I- I have one different- I'm- Fuck this area.
I'm actually leaving this area, bro.
Fuck this place.
I'm tired of the fucking fight there.
It's actually so dumb like i'm actually so tired of being
fighting there like oh my god everybody's there that's like
the worst part i like need loot i i forgot i still have two
more like one more life oh my god i can finally live in
peace fucking finally after being harassed for so long and
that one area but what if you bro fuck that shit bro i'm
like i'm not going back there i got fucking harassed for so
long that i couldn't leave like i legitimately was stuck
there for 20 years i feel like i've been topped this is the
longest i've been alive you know what you're right maybe i
should oh wait he has a home there hey but let me please Let
me have my loot at least Okay, I just want shield cells.
I don't want anything else just give me those shield cells
Guys it's a strafe it's a strafe.
I swear I swear the strafe is fucking me up I swear I wasn't
whiffing a strafe was so uncanny.
I swear to God
I kind of want to have win.
His strength!
It's the strength patterns!
Okay, I'm gonna grab this.
Maybe I can snipe with this.
Look, I lived for so long.
Don't fucking see.
With.
Wait, wait.
This is the longest I've lived in this game.
Oh my god.
This is hell.
I feel like solo modes is literally just sniping.
This is not fun.
I mean, I guess you can practice sniping, but still.
This shit is bullshit.
This is actually bullshit.
This is the game mode now.
This is solo mode.
Are you fucking...
Bro, please.
You and I both have to go to zone.
You have to come down, sir.
You're not in zone.
That's fucking right.
He's so confused.
Oh, fucking hell, this is not fair.
This is not fair!
Are you serious?
No!
Fuck off!
Bro, where did the Bangalore go?
Where the fuck is the Bangalore?
How did he say that?
A sniper took you, but I really give it...
No, fuck this game.
This game fucking sucks.
Fuck this game.
It's either...
a third priority or sniping that's it it really is open this
season good job on the sniper battle i swear not gonna lie i
liked it until until until you get sniped by 20 people randy
thank you for the super chat thank you thank you then we'll
see how much you like it all right i'm gonna a conduit i go
conduit i won't steal people's characters anymore
oh my god it's a bullshit actually is actually so fucking
bullshit it's not fair it's not fair at all as an introvert
apex player i like this game mode as a m you like this game
mode
bro i still can't believe that one area landed on and
everybody was just sniping each other from each building
each building just had its own sniper
It's not fair because they always come back.
Because when you kill them, they're going to come back and
shoot you in the back.
And they always arrive when I'm in a fight.
They always arrive when I'm in a fight.
That's the worst part.
That actually is the worst part.
They don't wait until, you know, to do a respectable 1v1.
They're like, no, I'm going to fuck this person so hard.
Get her out of that lobby.
hate that bitch.
A lot of people are using Mozam.
Is it good now?
Is there anybody here?
I don't think anybody's here.
I mean, I don't think anybody land here.
Are so many people running Mozam?
Is it good or not?
I can't tell.
Boink.
By now.
I don't think so.
Because none of this is... Oh!
JK JK There's a caustic here On me Okay Whoa No He's won
Please Please he's won Do the right thing And clutch There
you go he did it He did the right thing guys No that's one
guy No, he just knocked one person out.
I'm Resme.
I'm so Resme.
Guys, look at me.
This is what you get.
He was literally 1 HP.
This is what you fucking get.
Fucking please.
Where's our third?
Oh my god.
Where are you?
Save this man.
He's literally right here.
He's on my door.
He wants to mess me up.
He's right here.
What's the third me?
Oh no, he doesn't.
He's just running.
I think he's gonna lose.
That's...
He's definitely gonna lose this one.
1v1.
There's no way he wouldn't.
this there's no way there's no way he wins okay
i fucking knew it there's actually no way he wants us
all i'm saying is that if he is that man was there with us i
got my one i got my one we won know all about you but i got
my one it's always my team it's never me always remember
that dokey every time you die it's never your fault
are you gonna be the new coach for tsm okay first off we got
they gotta have a team first like
because it doesn't seem like there's going to be a tsm team
The moment.
It's actually crazy, though.
That's actually crazy.
Like, because, like, TSM has been, like, a team together for
so long.
Too soon.
Damn.
Please, let me play Alter.
I just want to play Alter.
Oh, sorry.
I upped the game volume a little bit, I don't know.
I let me tell my sound guy.
Boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
I don't know if it's, like, too loud or, like, if it's
better now.
TSM made this ban only.
Yeah, there's rumors that TSM...
Oh, my God, that's such a cute banner!
Wait, that's such a cute banner.
There's rumors that TSM made this ban.
And I feel like...
I feel like...
I feel like it might actually happen.
Because those tweets, those tweets from Reps and Verhals is
so sus.
Like, why would they tweet that?
Only in Apex.
Yeah, it's just Apex.
Apex rumors.
Did they land it on me?
No, they haven't.
I'm okay.
Okay.
Alright, 9.
Havoc.
And then, got my guns.
Got what I need.
Let's fight!
I won't get fuck over here, right?
Nope.
I knew I'll be okay.
Alright.
Evic.
Really?
Where?
Whoa!
I'm gonna stand here.
I don't think they know I'm here now.
If they know I'm here, they're stream sniping.
What the fuck was that?
Wait, how do I get back, though?
Oh, that's how.
Oh!
that spray was not oh okay that's fine that was not a good
whoa that's not fine
that's not fine that was not i'm okay now that's okay okay
we got a little merry girl around it's okay we're fine see i
told you we're fine nothing to worry about all right we're
gonna was not attractive right there.
I was not.
I didn't get rid of this.
Okay.
Let's see.
Calculate.
It was so calculated.
Of course it was.
Of course it was calculated.
I'm a gamer.
Oh, wait.
Alternator.
No.
They already used the disruptor.
Alright.
We're fine.
we're so okay let's see I really want to try wait we have
hammerpoint right wait actually I remember I saw a
hammerpoint back there I'm gonna grab it it's are not even
good no but I'm like coping at the moment
it's not I'm I'm just going through nostalgia with the R9.
That's why I got the...
That's why I got the vault.
Alright.
Back to the old days.
Bring me back.
Give me my nostalgia bait.
Please, I don't have anything else.
Let's see.
Care package over there.
Let's just go somewhere, guys.
Let's leave.
There's clearly no other teams here.
Yay!
I'm just gonna go straight.
I'm just gonna go straight here.
And also grab the armor.
There's no way I get shot in the air, right?
There's no way I land in the three teams.
Like, my bad luck is not that bad.
Give me season.
Okay, we're not going that further back, bro.
We're going back, but that's way...
You went too far.
That's a bit too far, bro.
I heard, like, shots here.
Let's see.
For me?
What the fuck is it?
Are they, like, rapping?
Like, what is that?
Oh, fuck!
Okay, there is a chance that my bad luck is that bad.
Maybe.
I'm putting off all the defenses right now.
Are you serious?
They were in fact serious.
Oh, wait.
I helped.
Oh, God.
I did it!
Oh, my God.
You're welcome.
You're absolutely welcome.
I feel like I deserve all that loot.
for everything I did.
Okay, I heard, like, shots from here.
There they are.
Okay, I'm climbing up this.
Holy shit, I did it, guys.
I clutched.
I assisted.
Watch this.
Do you watch it?
I told you to watch this
Did you watch it though?
I got my one
Did you watch it?
I got my one guys Okay, we're gonna get rid of the I didn't
get rid of the hammerpoint mozab I realized we're at more
Because I realized like My place
Guys no no no I didn't panic I didn't panic because I got my
ones I got my ones Wait what the fuck it disappeared Wait
that's so cool wait what how did he get over there wait what
how did he get over there holy shit what
oh my god you could do that because i think he knows how to
oh was that no that's not an all was that the all no way
that that can't be the uh because i saw the portal
I thought that was his cue.
Oh, it was?
Okay, I thought that was the cue.
I was, like, so surprised.
Like, what the fuck?
Alright.
I was like, there's no way he travels that far.
Oh, my God.
I'm fucking holding too many syringes.
Doink.
Let me grab this for...
For everybody.
Because I'm a team player.
Yay!
Where the fuck are the rest of the teams?
Guys, I need to break 1k.
Guys, I fucked up with...
Whoa!
Why am I so fast?
That arrow made me so fast.
My momentum was crazy there.
See, we need that.
Uh...
Anything for me?
Yoink.
Where is the...
Okay, we have to go back.
This is not even in the...
No, it wasn't my...
It wasn't my passive, though.
That's the thing.
Because everybody was close by.
Everyone was so close to me.
I can't be my passive.
I think it's the momentum of the stairs.
Yeah.
Wait, what?
The momentum of the stairs made me so fast.
Yeah, it's the stairs.
The stairs actually made me go zoom.
Whoa!
Don't worry!
You're okay!
Wait, where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
They have to come here, right?
There's no way that hits me.
I told you, there's no way that hits me.
No way this hits me, too.
I have the high ground.
Push in!
Come on, push in!
Alright, we should be able to push in now with this.
Oh god.
Alright.
Okay, goodbye!
Okay, goodbye.
Not the dead slide!
Oh no!
The fucking dead slide!
No!
Oh my god.
I can't believe I got dead slides so hard.
I got my one.
All I'm saying, I got my one.
Where the fuck were there one?
Not the slide.
Oh no!
My dead slides!
It fucked everything up!
It fucked everything what that could... Oh my god, this guy
is a fucking top 17 friend.
Bro, what are you doing?
Don't you want Fred again?
Bro, don't you want...
The death slide!
No!
I told you it's not me!
It's the game!
The game's sabotaging me!
It's sabotaged me!
Oh my god, he talks.
I guess any gun.
They're talking to each other.
They're letting each other know what guns they want.
What's a dead slide?
It's like when you try to slide for momentum, but you don't
get the momentum.
That's what it is.
That's a dead slide.
He speaks.
He has a mouth.
Isn't that crazy?
A fucking mouth.
Holy shit.
That's insane.
Alright.
Please!
I just want to play ULTAR!
Give me ULTAR!
That's right.
You don't even get Conduit.
If I can't get ULTAR, you can't get Conduit.
Number three.
Okay, it's the slide, but you don't get the actual slide
part.
It's pretty sad.
shouldn't have communicated look you can tell i i get worse
every season because what wait this is a three what this is
a three man fucking bread team
you can see i like my like every season i get worse because
my badges get lower
All right, here we go.
Where's my Pred players?
Where are they?
Where are my Pred players?
Jin-Jay, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
This is what happens when you get older.
That is not true.
That's a fucking lie.
VTubers don't age.
We're digital.
We can't age.
How dare you?
You're fucking kidding here, bro.
All right.
Oh, I should go to my teammate.
Oh, shit.
There's no way he sees me, right?
Told you, he doesn't see me.
Oh, bloody ass teammates!
Guys!
Oh, my!
Wait, there's night!
Okay, guys.
Okay, I fucked up.
There's another team.
Guys, don't come over here.
Everywhere I go, people die.
And by people, I mean me.
you bitch you bitch you have nothing in your life why are
you thirsty it's okay i'll slowly crawl i'm so safe i'm so
safe i'm so fucking safe ignore that guy shooting at you
ignore that one guy that shot you i'm so safe okay now that
you shot his friend he might shoot me there's another team
there oh my okay okay he might shoot me because you shot his
all right i'm good i'm good i'm good i'm so safe i am not
safe but like just pretend i am
really waiting for me though oh god surely he can't see that
right oh god i did it me kidding bro me too bro i don't have
med kits oh no Oh!
Okay, I have no ammo.
Oh my god, I actually have nothing.
I have nothing right now.
All I have is my fucking repeater.
Okay, I thirsted one guy.
I'm gonna loot this.
Here's a med kit, here's a med kit.
I'm gonna drop a med kit.
I have a med kit.
Nice.
I'm okay.
I helped.
I'm a team player.
Never forget.
Never back down.
I'm gonna fucking...
There's a full team right here on my feet.
I'm gonna grab this.
I don't have the ammo for this.
No, you're not.
No, you're not!
Whoa.
That was a no-brake!
I can't get out!
I got the core.
I've got the core.
where do you go from here where do we go from here oh my god
he's one he's actually one he's so low wait that's still
something to love you right here you're fucking fine wait
that's oh fuck okay give me a sec there's another team here
Bro, what the fuck is this?
Bro, chill!
Please!
Big TDM, bro.
Oh my god.
Oh, this is where I die.
What is that?
Shit!
What the fuck was that war?
Is this eye on that fucking boy?
Oh my god!
That's why I can't possibly know why I'm here right after I
shot them.
It was valiant but deadly.
Kaz, thank you and Super Chat, thank you, thank you.
Thank you extremely, oh how many birthdays she has in a
year.
Thank you for the Super Chat.
chat thank you it's merely just cosmetics guys it's really
bro chill oh my god that was actually crazy holy fuck oh my
god it never stopped the fight fighting's never i was
getting shot from 20 different directions there were shots
from angles i didn't know existed it was an online waffle
house it was absolutely insane bro what the fuck where's my
fucking pred team where's where's my like second and third
play who's also pred you can't get off mr.
bones wild ride that shit was so fucking wild
i guess they all want to try out broken moon want to go
through like the teams the proteins we where are they
landing oh my am I gonna get anything all right this is
where I die most likely guys this is exactly where I die
whoa whoa whoa whoa I thought I could climb
Do it, Sam!
We had a connection!
You were in my team!
Bro!
Oh my god.
I wasn't the first to die.
Death's doctor was.
No mercy.
I thought we had something.
thing i thought i thought we had something mad we were
literally on a team to get there how could you how could you
do this oh my god this was the pred team anyway so it
doesn't matter it does my team was not gonna survive that
you ditched him
i can't believe it did our fucking battle That not meant
anything.
It didn't mean anything to this person.
What the fuck?
I'm gonna leave this team.
I'm gonna leave the in the middle of everybody.
Oh my god.
I was destined to die there.
I truly was destined to die there.
all right that one guy okay that's a little bit better than
the user a bit better
all right here we go oh man i feel like this new this new
game mode this new season has made everybody wild
everybody's shooting at everything oh my god there's no
peace at all yay I get to play altar yeah oh shit wait
that's such a cool that's such a cool battle intro
joki you should have every that's different it's called
streamer privilege what content are they making when they're
shooting people
think of it that way Peace was not an intro.
They're not making content.
I am.
Alright.
They're just having fun?
What?
What's this word you're saying?
Fun.
Alright.
Is that new streamer?
moon all right let's see give me a gun give me a gun nice
like give me another gun i don't ask for much just two guns
okay this is my redemption arc jk i'm not fucking running
that what the fuck where are you getting shot from oh from
here watch this
Try to...
Okay.
Alright, this is awkward.
That was a little awkward.
Okay, I get that armor swap.
Oh, God.
Okay, we're fine.
No!
He used it against me!
okay okay i fucked up because i pressed q into two people
that was like that was my oopsie i i used my walls into two
people and i got instantly shot at that's so fucked up i'm
still learning i'm still learning your abilities Her
abilities are hard to master.
Her abilities.
Oh, wait.
Her teammates left her, too.
It's okay.
We have Clifford, the big red dog, and Sonic, the blue
hedgehog.
Surely nothing can go wrong.
Oh, my God.
The crossover of a fucking century.
Sounds like a skill issue.
Okay.
This is it.
This is the crossover we needed.
This is the crossover that will give us the win.
The strong duo.
Yes.
Like, with those names, with those names, this duo is
unstoppable.
I knew it.
I knew Clifford would be a 4K 20 bomb.
At his size, he could just...
He just squished him.
Oh my god.
He could just squished him with his sheer size.
a bird a dog and a hedgehog what could go wrong god that's
one hell of a powerful team bro he could kill 20 people with
just one step clifford the big red guy this has to be
winnable okay actually i actually i should not have peaced
out because like everybody lands here so i'm I'm a little
fucking scared.
Alright.
Okay, into the hole I go.
The hole is the goal.
Three people sharing this one hole.
Seems ideal.
Surely nothing can go wrong when he does that.
See?
There we go.
Nothing went wrong.
Oh, I can go back up.
Wait, what?
I can, but I just chose not to.
Guys, I just chose not to go up.
Wait, where are you?
Oh, wait, on me.
It's on me.
Whoa.
Okay, that was a cool hit fire.
You got him in.
Nice.
Wait, where's your teammate?
Where is your teammate?
me okay we gotta get rid of i want to use the triple take
okay all right so i don't have ammo for the triple take
that's okay choices no i chose not to go not to go that way
because i wanted to flank it was all a choice my choices
matter where the fuck are oh there it is Nice.
All right.
Let's go.
Let's flag.
Here we go.
Come on, Sonic.
You got this.
You got to go fast.
Is he going to do the thing?
What is he?
He's trying to go inside.
He's like, fine.
I'll use the door.
Oh, shit.
I like how he's like, I guess I'll use the door.
This is another team.
Yeah, this is...
Oh, God.
I'm trying to cover.
Alright, here we go.
Don't worry, I got you!
I got you!
Cover me!
Cover me, Sonic!
Okay, nice.
The flank!
but the flank whoa okay that was a good name not gonna lie
that's why you're not getting res because i need your loot
where is he is he gonna melee him you'll be fine right oh i
contributed let's see i need that i need like a prowler i
feel like where's his teammate teammate
teammate i mean there's a spray
i see the spray there's no way he's gonna shoot me while i
craft right that'll be up it's like how like like guys have
like the bro code where you should never no nutshots ever
and then this is like this is the girl code never shoot
somebody when they're crafting that's
It can be applied in any situation.
That's the girl code.
Or that way.
Okay.
Is that how it works?
Let's show it to our loud under some rules.
That man is not a bro.
Who said that?
I always go, that's fucked up.
You're not a bro, bro.
Bro.
Wow, grows are complicated.
I did it.
Look, I did it.
You saw that Zoink saw killed him.
Damn.
You're never safe from a nutshot.
Alright, let's see.
I'm gonna grab this.
And then...
I'm helping.
I need, like, a fucking prowler.
I just, oh, no.
Oh, I can cancel.
Okay.
That was an accident.
Wait, what?
Where?
Oh, there.
There.
No, where?
I can go in too.
Where am I?
Whoa, that's where I am.
I need your armor swap.
Nice.
Everything is going the way we planned it.
Where's his teammate?
Oh, there it is.
Go, Clifford!
Go!
I knew I could always believe in Clifford.
Oh, thank God.
I need this prowler.
There you go.
The greatest sign of trust is letting your bro hold you
right now.
Anybody want to...
So how many hut nuts did you hold?
Is that true, bro?
Does he speak for all the other...
bros is he so like you know like trust falls you know how
people have like trust falls do you guys have like trust
nuts is that what it's called not true yeah bro bro what if
you've never had your bro hold your nut is he really your
bro in the first place i don't understand bro yeah it's a
it's a All I'm saying All I'm saying If he's your best
friend If he's your best bro Prove it with a trust nut I
know it's just That would trust True homies have the perfect
ads Yeah exactly Like You gotta know if he's a real bro.
Let me hold the nuts, bro.
Kazik, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Yeah.
Okay, so it's like, you know how people have, like, best
man?
Is he really your best man if he has?
If he has, if he has, if you haven't trusted him with the
nuts.
What the hell is a trap?
It's when a bro, like...
It's when a bro holds it tenderly.
It's when you trust him with everything you have.
Trust him with the future kids.
You know, bro.
Oh my god, I was like duck hunting for that guy.
I literally was...
That was fucked up.
get up there bro i can't shoot this guy
there you go holy shit yeah trust them with the potential
kids exactly if you had to ask what it is you never had a
real bro then i've seen bros hold the in your thighs but
You never had a real bro.
I'm sorry to say this man.
I'm sorry to tell you this You've never had a real bro a
real bro would not have to ask Also, they wouldn't have to
ask he bro want to feel my blood
That's all I'm seeing
Wait, life team oh my god I knew it I knew this duo was
unstoppable bro what is this calm wait I hear them they're
like inside the they're inside the big shield if that's your
real definition of a real bro I don't need it bro and you
don't trust your bro you don't trust them how can you have a
best man if you can't even trust him if you can't even trust
him with the future children Wait so girls holding each
other each girl's over no because women don't trust each
other All right
Toki stop
So true and rude There we go downstairs
Hey, oh wait over there What the that's a that's a solo,
please
Oh my god, we just walk here that that was the game I knew I
knew it I knew I knew this team was it i fucking knew it i
knew i had this team this team was it oh god please okay i
knew clifford the big red dog it's sonic that blue hedgehog
i knew it that was easy effortless shit i know right i trust
my bros i just i don't want to worry anymore
cosmic thank you for the super chat thank you thank you you
can't trust your nuts with me bro for your future bro thank
you for the super chat thank you thank you i knew no no my
fucking bros dokey the big yellow bird there you go i can't
believe it the most effortless game i had and all i did this
caught truly the game of all time bro it's over
all right oh wait they won too they also won but their names
are not as funny do they are they truly winners that their
names aren't even funny is bro over all right we're here
we're ready Yeah, are you getting away with this?
Alright.
We're here.
We're here!
Yeah!
Yay!
Looking for a new bro, the last one that I don't want to
trust.
Mr. Toot, thank you for the superture.
Thank you, thank you.
Guys, I'm pretty sure a dragoon here out there will do the
trust nut with you.
I'm pretty sure.
Any dragoons that want to take his offer?
All right, let's go.
Turkey, stop.
Oh, shit!
It's fine.
Watch this.
They won't expect it.
Oh, fuck!
I didn't expect that!
They're right.
I definitely didn't expect it.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna help.
Oh, wait, never mind.
I was gonna climb up and help him.
Boom.
Alright.
They did expect it.
No, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
There's something of surreal about hearing your Oshi talk
about the trust net while following Sonic the Bluehead Chog
around.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
It's just, it's just, it's just making sure, you know, if
you can trust your bro that's okay he's he's fine he's so
fine wait is this guy that guy was pred you fucking idiot
wait what pred are you pred at top what oh my god this guy
you're garbage
now that's a that's a distrust nut what i did there all
right there's people little bit here.
Alright.
Different kind of tribe.
Where did you get shot from?
Ooh, yoink.
Oh, that's nothing to yoink from there.
Oh wait, what the fuck?
I'm going in.
JK.
Haha, JK.
We're all dead.
I'm gonna steal this real fast.
Oh, wait.
Watch this.
Oh!
That was scary.
Oh, shit.
More people are coming.
There's people here.
I have to go up the old-fashioned way.
Give me...
me a sec send highlights i feel like that's cool wait below
me what the are they doing below me yeah i was gonna say
what are they doing down there nice see we're winning we're
doing it it's like a delivery oh this is so cool we actually
like this ability a lot actually no three and a two x yes
five
Wait, who's shooting at?
Wait, what?
Oh, bro.
Bro, this is not good, bro.
Bro, this is not good.
Never mind.
It's all good now.
Never mind, bro.
It's all good.
It's fine.
Watch this.
Where does this go?
Guys, i found out where it went
hey guys i figured out where it went it was not a place i
wanted to go though
oh no bro bro bro no bro no oh fuck okay where is he
I'm looking I'm looking I'm looking What
Trying to cover you I'm trying to cover you right now bro
Don't worry bro Don't worry bro I got you bro I told you I
got you bro It's trust not time Oh I'm me Okay Watch this.
Where?
Oh shit.
Oh, where am I?
Where am I going?
Bro, stop.
I trusted too hard.
No witness.
All right, see, we're winning now.
Every time you use your ability, you get lost.
I just, there's a lot of things going on.
You get lost, too.
You have to go through what I went through.
There's so many things around me.
Guys, it's not a me issue.
It's an everybody issue.
You just don't understand.
You just didn't live through what I lived through.
Broken that chest.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I literally clutched this for my team.
I clutched this.
You don't understand.
Wait, what?
Where are they shooting at?
Where do we go?
That's my first day, exactly.
This hero literally, this legend literally just got
released, guys.
What do you want from me?
I'm learning it live with all of you.
Let's see.
I mean, we could just...
Can we not put this out here?
We cannot?
That's bullshit.
Wait, we can't.
That's actually bullshit.
I'm gonna put this here.
And then take this.
I leave.
Wow!
I leave now.
Wait, what?
Bro, we crossed paths!
We crossed streams!
What the fuck?
What the fuck was that?
We actually crossed streams.
Bro!
Bro, you like fucked them up.
What happened almost time streams?
bro it was like like out of nowhere i was like who the fuck
is that all right mine's a little red i think i might see a
doctor all right my next is no longer all right that
happened this is why he don't cross streams
oh shit
Well, he's over there Whoa, yeah, I'm fucking going back
Goodbye Yeah, that's a little bit too much Whoa, they're
putting your whole army Alright, there you go
The entire army fucking came over to me What the fuck?
Yeah, what's going on?
What the hell?
Is he behind?
Okay, that was very...
That was a very ballsy of them.
Alright, nice.
That was actually so confident that...
Holy shit.
I still have one more charge.
I do.
Wait, no, I don't.
Okay, let's see.
I'm going to grab that.
Yeah!
Very ambitious.
Yeah.
Very fucking ambitious.
Those free kills.
See, if I had nickel every time Doki said, watch this, and I
immediately jump scared, I could possibly play for a super
chat.
I agree with a super chat.
Thank you.
All right, where's another team?
We gotta go this way, guys.
Guys, I just realized he's live.
Oh my god.
I feel he's finesse.
Let's go.
Where do we go?
Oh, this is new.
I've went through this before.
To be fair, this map has been, like, blurring together for
me.
All right, let's see.
Down, not go.
Wait, I can just drop down.
Oh, it's like, this is like the storm point thing.
It's a trespass ball again.
Okay, watch.
Nobody.
Okay, thank God.
Every time I go through those portals, I just hope there's
nobody there.
over here there's people here though on me
it's up here too oh
oh that was not supposed to happen but i take those wait
what right there Where are they?
I hear them.
Hey.
Back I go.
Yeah, they were up top.
No one there heard them.
Is he still up there?
There's no way.
Wait, what the fuck?
There's a crypto dude.
Don't worry.
Surely he's not down here again.
Oh, he isn't.
Don't worry, bro!
Got you!
Bro, I got you, bro!
Okay.
Nice.
I told you I got this, man.
I gotta go this way.
Okay.
Let's see.
The last three squads are shooting at each other, I think.
Yeah, they are.
there's no way I could get fucked over here there you go
there's no way there's no way they're just gonna shoot back
at me you're too stupid for that and the other team is like
they were looking at another team on my right side whoa okay
I just realized I don't have a lot of ammo but it's okay
it's okay everything fine surely it'll be okay right yeah
surely it'll be okay me and my oh wait i knew it i knew
things would be okay everything always looks up for me i
knew it but they have to drop down right no they don't wait
can i like go up from here like how fucked would i be
Don't go up!
Whoa!
Guys, yeah, I'm not doing that again.
Who would have thought it'd be pretty bad?
Who would have thought?
It'd be pretty fucking bad.
Oh my god, they- wait, they have red armor.
Wait a minute.
How long have they been here?
Guys, guys, I'm gonna come with you.
Do it again.
It'll be so funny.
Okay, but like, what if I do this?
Watch this.
What if I- Okay, death 30, 30.
Oh no, what if I- It would be so fun, you know.
Okay, let me actually contribute to this fight.
Okay, let me actually contribute.
We actually have to be part of this game now.
I think it's like...
one guy.
Not gonna lie, I'm pretty sure.
Wait, he just walked behind.
There's no way.
He literally just walked in the back.
But where is this other team?
Oh, shit.
Come back.
Look, look, look.
I'm helping.
I'm covering.
Jesus Christ.
Guys, cheer!
Fucking chea!
Wait, what?
I heard people.
Right behind us.
Oh, God.
Give me a shot at while I do this.
They're, like, right here.
What is he trying to do?
Waste our ammo?
Like, what is he trying to do?
Oh, my God.
These guys are so annoying.
No, they are so fucking annoying.
annoying So annoying.
Holy shit Guys fucking chill Don't have a lot of shields.
Okay, I have zero shield cells left.
Okay
Bro, how do you still have ammo?
Oh my god, bro fuck off The fucking jiggle peek from the
crypto Are you serious?
The crypto has a goddamn jiggle peak.
That's actually so funny.
Okay, we'll put it here.
Alright, here we go.
There.
What a waste of a crypto.
Wait, what?
Okay, I'm gonna cover the left side just in case.
What was that?
Are you serious?
What a fucking move.
I'm gonna I'm gonna do this just in case.
Wait, are they dead?
Where are they?
Who else is?
Wait, this is a rock.
Okay.
effort effort i was gonna say why would you up that oh no
he's down where is he i fucked up where okay i see him
no this is no don't let him press please my teammate bro
he's so low he was actually so low man bro it's one one guy
I told that don't let don't let him raise literally one guy
literally it's literally one guy we did so much okay all
right there we go we did it we won oh my god you got kick
one Bro, he almost got one guide!
Oh my god, we did it.
I did the most I can do.
See?
Middle of the pack.
Consistently.
Consistently averaged.
Look, we are consistently averaged.
Stop being scared.
Back to back.
Back to fucking up.
Back guys She's so mid
14 kills got bro, that guy stole is a kill stealer 14 kills
with 2.5 K I had 4 kills with 2 K that man's a kill stealer
Bro, I don't want to play I don't want to play fucking
Conway, I won't play altar No women like toky.
Bro, fuck this team.
I'm going to leave this.
No, you know what?
I'll let this team die.
And my suffering.
Oh my god.
This guy's not having a good time.
All right.
We're going to go full in death.
Everybody will die here.
Shake my head.
My oh, she is mid.
All right.
I gladness to death.
We're all gonna die here.
Bro needs to log off.
We're getting all wins today.
Guys.
I wouldn't trust that, bro.
Alright, here we go.
We're getting all wins, which is nice.
Can you guys have 700k?
Thank you, Min.
Go to hell.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you, everybody.
I really appreciate it.
Thank you, guys.
Oh.
See?
There he goes.
Surely they'll be fine, right?
I should, like... Wow!
Hey, guys.
Oh, one guy left already.
That's what you get.
Oh, they both left.
Alright.
Finally, I can leave as well.
This is a different game.
Nice.
Oh, my god.
I can feel the fucking R&D I'm getting there.
Do peek me right here.
Okay.
Yeah.
That's what he did.
I did.
He did.
How is I supposed to know that he knew I was there?
Now my pro and dozer is not trust or is he?
How is that?
Oh, and they're running?
These cowards.
I wish they...
These fucking cowards.
Not even two seconds.
Do you think he saw me, guys?
I can't believe it.
They're fucking running?
In a pub?
What are you?
Can't believe it.
If I don't get ultra, I leave.
Oh.
I stay.
Yay!
Yes, I stay.
Nice.
I'm glad Ducky is keeping to the script today.
Alter or leave.
Rad, welcome to the tomato farm.
I really love this banner.
It's so cute.
Thank you for the... Welcome to the tomato farm.
Welcome, welcome.
No.
I don't want to be jump master.
Alright.
Ultra or troll exactly.
Not nicely possessive.
What do you mean?
She speaks Cantonese.
I speak Cantonese.
We are...
Good bros.
Top 10 clothes before disaster He's basically me Wait, what?
Oh shit Yeah, those are definitely enemies
Okay, I did not expect them to Oh, they locked her in I'm so
fucked up Bro, holy shit That's so fucked up!
Oh my god.
I got shot by three different people.
Look at that.
They have to be squatted up.
Bro, there's no way.
There's no way that team is like not in a voice call right
now.
That was so coordinated.
Okay, but guys, that shit was incredibly coordinated.
That was actually crazy.
how corny they were literally snared fucking snared locked
us in and they said get that bitch that was so fucking crazy
it was like and they literally I'm pretty sure they did a
countdown too it was 3 2 1 yeah no altar I leave let me
leave It's okay, we'll let random.
They're giving you each other trust nuts now.
Like, we wish your teammates are like this.
They prepped this for a week.
Dude, I feel like they had a plan, too.
I leave.
That's fucking right.
That is sick.
Did they say something like, wait, this is a streamer?
And I left.
It's like a Wild West site.
Yeah Yeah, it's like a it's like a wild west sighting there
like you see a dokey bird like like it's like bird watching
You see dokey bird for one second and then she's gone and it
was a legend
The one second of dokey bird before she disappears forever
Oh my god, we're gonna third wheel this date I don't even
know what we're gonna third wheel this date Little bird
watching bird seating
Oh shit, there's that that's a roller player Oh my god, it's
okay
Ask him about the trust they should have took the picture
before it's okay I'm logged in into their bird watching I'm
in the log.
Where do we go?
I'm the third wheel.
Take us here.
It'd be a great date.
It's a life and death date.
Oh my god, she took us there!
I mean, it ain't a real date until somebody might die.
They're all terrible.
But at least they got rid of promenade.
Alright, let's see.
We're gonna loot in the best kind of dates exactly Is it
really a date unless like you know the threat of death is
like looming over your heads All right, let's see I got a
nemesis and a wingman that is too long range at the same
time Oh my god, I got you Oh, I got through the rock you man
I got you bro I got one of them no you're not you really ran
into a difficult all I'm saying is he did not get chased he
definitely did not get jeez i literally blocked him from
getting the data said they're both dead oh this team here
this i was running away and the first thing they do is like
oh let me go face that man i was just like what do you mean
you're getting chased i literally got two of them away from
you hit me with that pk bro that sucks man guys isn't we're
like it's like we're like we're ease droppers too like we're
that we're the eye and the wall but not like the voyeuristic
way like not the creepy voyeuristic way because they know
i'm here so they consented i think i
again okay we're not i don't want to do it twice i mean
that's Sounds worse.
They know I'm here.
So it's not my fault if we're listening in.
You're worried.
4K people watching Bros Day.
Look, we're judging them.
Guys, I just don't want to hear it.
Don't want to be in an awkward third wheel again.
Like, okay, if there was like a little like intermission
between it, that's fine.
But there wasn't.
in twice in a row like look I want to listen in on other
people's stuff awkward okay mr.
rat don't know no no please please I'm streaming I'll give
you five dollars no I can't type fast enough I can't I can't
type fast enough
No!
Let me play Alter!
What if I leave this one too?
I just want to leave I want to play Alter.
She's mean!
She's literally mean!
I bet this man doesn't even speak Cantonese.
I'm going to take us to death.
Okay, what is death number two?
Here.
Cry more.
There we go here.
Alright, this is where we go.
Here we go.
Alright.
Death number two.
No altar.
Then death.
We must go.
We got a lot of wins though today.
Okay.
just in case I need oh nice they ran away that's even better
but it's such a waste though wait what you didn't run away
really you should have ran away bitch well maybe I oh you
should have ran away little boy that was the wrong thing you
did nice yay I leveled up!
Okay, I'm gonna heal real fast.
Right in my mouth, you go.
I'm gonna eat you up.
Alright, nice.
Okay, I need a...
Oh, she has a podcast?
Where are they?
I'm gonna scare that I don't know where they are.
I'll give you an amp first.
Wait, they're not...
Who did I...
Did I give nobody amp?
Whoops.
That's awkward.
Oh, great.
I wasted it.
Oh, what?
Where are they?
Where the fuck are they?
I know there's another team here.
I know there is.
I'm too scared to go down.
Oh, my God.
I knew I heard them.
They're right below us.
Mr. Rat, go in there, Mr. Rat.
fucking right.
But they didn't expect a second person.
That's fucking right.
Or the third.
Oh, yeah?
I can go up there, too.
That's fucking right.
Give me your money.
Give me your lunch money.
Bro, I'm trusting my bro.
Just giving my daily trust.
All right, let's see.
Let's try the wingbang again.
Nice.
I'm locked in.
$5 for Doki.
JT, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
I appreciate it, man.
Thank you so much.
All right, let's get rid of these.
Surely.
Yeah, it's Trustnut.
I told you.
It's not toxic.
I'm trusting him.
all right let's see what's the oh oh wait i hear people
they're like right here i hear the res the tea and tea bag
sounds for teamwork exactly somebody gets it i'm glad
somebody gets it now oh shit there's a fight oh my god
pillow princess you go girl
Watch this.
I'm gonna take it?
This is not the chestnut.
You see, you wait until they're done.
You wait until they res.
So, like...
So you don't have to do anything at all.
That's my favorite part.
When you just wait for them to res.
So you don't actually have to do real work.
When it comes to fighting, I feel like right here I see
them.
Where's my portal?
Where's my alt?
What the fuck?
Who is this guy?
What the fuck is this random guy?
Okay, I think I might accidentally need myself.
I have to make sure I don't accidentally need myself.
Where are they?
Wait, where did he res?
What the matter?
Okay, I was gonna say it.
I thought the guy that fucking jumped in was my own team.
Like, I was like, what the fuck?
Bro, I'm on your team, bro.
I was like, I can't believe my team didn't fucking jump in
with me.
That's fucked up, bro.
Sacrifice.
I'm a conduit.
be sacrificing my life.
I could have played Backline, but I didn't.
Because I trusted my team.
I'm so messed up.
Did I hear anything?
No, that wasn't it.
I heard something.
Oh, it's so messed up.
They're like, they went in there with them.
Like, I went in there and they didn't follow me up.
I have too many mid-kits.
Alright, let's go to zone.
Wait, I could grab...
I'm gonna grab this armor, and then I'll go to zone.
Yeah.
It wasn't...
It didn't, like, reciprocate.
That...
You have to make sure you both reciprocate.
There, like, a railing here?
Nice, there is.
Nice.
Okay.
Notice this isn't on the map anymore.
The railings?
Usually they're on the map, but they're not.
Or, like, this one wasn't.
Oh!
Who hit me?
Oh, he has red armor.
Oh, shit.
That's when you know they've been gaming.
Where are they?
It's right there.
Let's see.
No!
get closer not that close I didn't mean you I didn't mean
you I meant the under lifeline I didn't mean this pathfinder
there's a guy right here what the fuck wait that's a
different guy oh god oh god please I can't
made it!
Oh my god!
Thank you.
What the fuck?
I made it.
Oh my god.
I fucking made it.
Run.
That was close.
That was actually...
That was clutch.
That was a good ult.
What a...
My hero.
That was actually an incredible ult.
She saved my life.
Do we follow him on the seats of her cheeks?
I did not expect her to actually help me.
That's insane.
Alright, let's go.
Surely we're not gonna let everybody know we're here, right?
Oh, wee!
The trust.
Told you in the trust bag.
I knew it existed.
I'm gonna grab this too.
red armor all right we're in zone i need to craft some bat a
bat for wasting my bats there earlier yeah all right got my
bat that's actually crazy though the fucking uh the fucking
all actually saved my life because i'm sure those are two
teams that had to be two teams.
There's no way.
There's no fucking way it was not two teams.
Where could they be?
Oh.
Care package.
What's in it?
What's in the care package?
Sir, look up.
Look up, sir.
Look up and tell me what's in the package.
Please!
All you have to do is look up!
I'm gonna please rat mr.
rat That's all you have to do just look up That's all I want
Oh, okay, there we go.
He looked up guys.
It only took him 20 years But he finally did it He
accomplished something that no man has ever done before
looking up.
Okay, that was a sick shot from how far?
I was looking at.
I should be at all.
I thought that would be like a armor upgrade.
Where is he?
Get shit on.
Alright.
Gamers don't look up.
He accomplished something new today.
Is that an angle here?
I do.
Oh, that would have been so cool if I hit that like over
there.
Let's see.
Wait, what?
Oh, shit, Mr. Rat!
The world got you!
They're so, like, they can't crawl up.
Nice.
I just didn't want them to crawl up.
Oh, wait, there's another fight here, too.
Wait, I want to fight this guy as well.
They're, like, from each other.
And there's the Lifeline as well.
Hey, the Lifeline team won?
Oh my god, it's the goddamn triple- Bro, fuck off!
It's the goddamn triple-take Lifeline!
I'm trying to figure out where, like...
There we go.
Yeah, fuck you.
Thanks for the red armor loser.
Oh, shit!
Wow!
Let me in.
Wait, let me in.
Wait, is he only shot at now?
Okay, that was a little fucking scary.
Are we just gonna go to zone?
Alright.
I can deal with that.
I just have better...
I just have high ground, you know?
We love high ground here.
Wait, are we fighting?
fighting?
Where are we doing?
What's the decision, Mr. Rat?
Let me in.
I feel like this person actually knows how to play Alter
more than me.
Not sure.
My portals are just Hell Marys.
It's just like, will this work?
Those are those are my... Whoa!
Shit!
Oh.
Guess I...
Guess I leave.
Yes, I leave.
Bye.
Alright, here you go.
Yeah, her portos are for some reason 100% better than mine.
I don't know how she does it.
For some very odd reason, they really know how to port them.
I want them to push into the other team.
Bro, stop!
Stop!
They're running at each other, they're running each other!
Wait, we should run at each other!
They're running, they're running!
Let's go, let's go, let's go!
They're not running at each other anymore.
Okay, I'll take this.
What the fuck, he's so fast!
He's so fast!
Did you see that?
He's so fast.
Bro, he's zoomed.
I cracked him.
He was so fucking fast, man.
I got him.
I don't want him to get raised.
Okay.
What?
Oh my god, he helped.
Guys, please.
Please don't lose this.
Please don't lose.
No, they're gonna rest.
Where's my team?
No!
Rest.
No, guys, no!
No, that's their route.
Where's my team?
No!
Bro, if we rushed them, we win!
I really gotta knock.
I gotta knock for us.
No!
Oh my god.
Thanks.
I can't believe it.
Bro, it's over.
This is why if I don't get ulterior hits over.
I gotta knock at everything.
I did so much damage.
Where was my team?
Look, all I'm saying was I did my part.
I did my part of this game.
We'll do one more.
We'll do one more trios and then one more solo.
It was so winnable.
It was so fucking winnable.
I fucking...
She didn't trust.
Yeah, I held my hand out.
I held...
I don't stand.
I don't even trust.
Oh my god.
Okay, my fucking bow check aim was fucking crazy.
I was actually going nuclear there with my bow check.
I can't believe it.
How could they do this to me?
All right.
This is it.
waste.
I know!
They wasted my effort!
Okay, my favorite part was the fucking guy that was zooming
though.
That, the fucking ulti that just fucking zoom as they crawl
to their fucking death.
I know, how could it not trust me?
Like, this is the face of somebody that's trustworthy and
wouldn't let you die.
have flatline.
Oh my gosh, I haven't used flatline so long.
Let's see.
Okay.
Nice.
I needed the hollow on the flattie.
I don't like it on this.
Alright.
Here we go.
Oh, shit.
Creepy Slay.
Don't worry.
I got you.
Trust.
See?
I hit one shot out of four.
Oh my god.
Wait.
He needs help.
Okay.
I'm coming over.
I don't know where this is gonna go.
There.
I told you!
Trust!
Nice.
We did it.
Easy.
Fucking easy.
It's all about the trust, baby.
Okay, extend highlights, reduce, alter.
I don't think I need the alt.
I like the...
the hell thing more i did it excuse me i have one kill i got
my one
see uh you know what i want to do more wingy surely i'll
eventually hit those shots surely truly
i believe it's all about believing in myself too i try trust
myself as well.
Alright.
Wait, they're all taking the rail.
Let me, let me on.
Let me on the rail.
I want to get on the ride.
I want to get on the crazy ride.
That's all about coping.
I'll hit, might hit, okay, look.
I hit at least one shot.
And that's more, more than more than
It's more than chat.
All I'm saying.
All right.
Let's see.
Woo!
Whoa!
All I'm saying, I don't know.
That's all I'm saying.
I don't know.
Wait, people died here.
So I can steal this loot.
Yoink.
Oh my god, look at all this free loot.
Wait, this is amazing.
Noink.
Where?
Oh, there!
Okay, let me bring up the other gun.
Let me bring...
Let me bring up the gun that I...
That I can actually hit.
Okay, there we go.
Yay.
Look, I still hit those.
I still hit it, guys.
Shit, I actually tabbed out.
We've all been there before.
Okay, nice.
Watch your craft the bat.
Yay.
Anything else I haven't looted yet?
Oh, What the fuck?
I should...
Whoa!
Wait, I don't like that.
That's funny.
They, like, fucking spat out a battery in front of me.
Let's see.
That's enough.
You guys think I have too many bats?
No, right?
Nah.
I should grab a sniper, too.
Alright, here we go.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry.
I'm here.
I'm gonna put this here.
It's alright.
We can fall back if we need to.
I believe.
I feel like we don't need that many.
Okay, I definitely need more shield cells, though.
Where?
There?
Even Octane was like, what
the...
Even Octane was like, hmm.
Oh my god.
Oh,
he's so low.
Oh my god, he's so low too.
Oh god, the last guy's on me.
Oh god, he's not gonna look at me, right?
Bro, I'm so confused.
He's like, where the fuck did this go?
And he was like, what the fuck?
Did I hear him?
I hear... What?!
Oh, he was on me this entire time.
Wait, this is a different guy!
He wasn't on me this entire time!
He was a new guy!
There,
he's dead.
There you go.
I have to think for a little bit.
There you go, we're fine.
I gotta think, but it's okay.
Let's see.
We did it.
We fucking did it, guys.
We're our team.
Yay!
Okay, I'm gonna get rid of...
It's not that I don't believe in myself.
It's that like...
Guys, it's not about a lack of belief at the moment.
It's just that I think it'd be better if I use this gun
instead.
Just a little better.
I totally believe in myself.
Okay, let's see.
Is there like a 3x?
Ooh, there is.
Oh, whoops.
I got rid of my 2x.
Whoops.
Okay.
No!
I got rid of my 2x!
I forgot to fuck up!
It's so far away!
Jokey's cool down on wingman.
Yeah, I like used up my wingman cool down, guys.
It's so unfortunate.
It's so unfortunate, guys.
Let's see.
Oh, this way.
Wee!
Back.
Yay!
This game is so easy.
Do I need a crafter bat?
No, I have six bats.
We're five.
I need 2x, though.
I need a 2x for this.
Or...
I like flatline and 2x because I feel like it's just better.
Just a better scope.
Oh.
Where are they?
They're right here?
Oh my god!
They're just chilling.
Oh, it's two guys but it's two guys whoa i'm so fast it's
literally two instead of one guy we get two guys
no shield is gonna protect you all right this is it oh they
saw us too they'll do and they know they know it's a 3v2 now
they're fucking Oh, is he looking at me?
Wait, does this guy have a 2x?
No.
No 2x.
Wait, I hear him.
You're over there.
Oh, shit!
Oh, my god.
Oh, fuck, okay.
Okay.
Don't look at me!
It's okay, we did it.
Oh, my god, that was scary.
There's no way he dies.
right?
Oh my god, they looked at me.
Yay!
We did it!
Yeah!
So easy.
The donking distractions.
They looked at me.
I was so scared.
No, Doric, it stopped me.
They thought I would take, oh my god, none of us broke 1k.
That is so sad.
None of us.
We have like a bread player.
None of us broke one game.
I like how I could have used the door.
But I didn't.
I was just like.
They'll never expect it.
They never expected guys.
They are all looking at the door.
Thinking I'd pop up.
But I wasn't using that door.
all right we'll do one uh we'll do uh we'll do one more solo
and then we'll call it here because we have another stream
in an hour another hour and 20 minutes all right here we go
Here we go.
Alright, solo mode.
We're all dreams die.
Yeah, doors are for port-y.
I bought the DLC.
I don't need to use doors anymore.
Alright, here we go.
Last game.
This might be a really fast game.
Honestly, this could be a very fast game.
Nobody to fight for Altair.
Alright, here we go.
Alright, this is it.
Yeah!
What's it mean?
Loba's cheeks, 69.420.
That seems right.
Alright, we go to our favorite place.
where's the sniper perch if I'm going to snipe I might as
well go here it's sniping time alright this is my only safe
place this place made me live the longest so like I feel the
safest honestly this is like the only place that I feel safe
at the moment
enemies nearby not anymore we don't think anyone lands here
that's good thank god thank fucking god for now this place
is my sanctuary out of all the solo modes i played this was
the only area that i lived the longest so i literally you
don't trust anywhere else
You need an actual sniper, though.
Like, I found, like, a repeater with the PK.
There's nobody here.
Thank God.
Oh.
Either works, you know.
Okay, where the fuck are the snipers?
How am I supposed to snipe if I don't have the one thing I
need?
Okay.
Are you serious?
Where the fuck are the snipers?
Wait, you hear that?
Wait, wait a minute.
I didn't loot that.
Wait a minute, what are you doing here?
What are you doing?
This is my strat!
What are you doing here?
Oh no.
That's fucking right, bitch.
Yeah, you think that's gonna stop me?
Oh.
Oh, guys, I broke-
Guys, it might have stopped me.
Oh my gosh!
He's shooting my feet!
AHHHHH!
Oh my god!
Wait, what the fuck?
Oh no way!
No fucking way!
That's a It's actually not fair.
My god.
I would have fought that with you.
Bro, this game fucking...
There's no fucking way.
That's actually bullshit.
Bro!
Bro, stop!
I went through so much, bro.
Not fair.
That's not fair!
I went through so much, man!
I didn't...
Putting a pound!
I can't believe it actually stopped me!
What is this?
Bro, it actually stopped me!
Wait, what?
Oh, it's here.
Yeah, you thought Tap Street's gonna fucking save you?
Okay.
Might need arms.
Might need shoes, though.
Oh, that's smart.
No.
Oh, shit.
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no!
I'm so sad.
I'm so sad I got I got fucked so hot You know what That That
bug I think that was a good time to call it
What a game To end it on What a game To end it on What a
game to end it on Okay, guys, we're calling here.
I have another stream later today in an hour, so...
I still can't believe...
I can't believe that I'm hungry.
How am I the one...
Why?
Anyway, we have a Tekken 8 stream next.
A great time, though, playing a new season.
As always, everybody, say hi.
Dream it, pause, check.
Get up and move around to get that blood flowing.
And you say it up for me.
Say it a little longer for me to play.
Tekken 8 for the first time ever.
I'll see you guys next time, everybody.
Bye, guys.
Bye.
Also, slightly new ending screen.
You'll see now.
Bye.